euh on va passer tout de suite au
dossier du jour on va parler d'un sujet
sur lequel tout le monde sa'est déjà
pour forcément poser la question la vie
après la mort et personne ne sait
réellement ce qui se passe après la mort
à part Daniel et nombreux sont ceux qui
ont tenté de l'expliquer on va justement
recevoir l'un d'entre eux Stéphan Alix
ancien reporter de guerre qui a
récemment publié les résultats de 15 ans
d'enquête sur l'après-vie il sera
accompagné de Laura euh qui a vécu euh
une expérience de mort imminente qu'elle
raconte également dans un livre euh
regardez ça ça passionne tout le monde
vous allez voir ce qu'il raconte euh
c'est fou hein après on est on est
rassuré en fait voyez ou pas moi je
DIRIS que j'avais toujours peur pour
vous Daniel Gill et tout B maintenant je
dis c'est pas grave ça va faire du bien
ça va faire du
important alors que la fête des défuns a
lieu aujourd'hui de nombreux Français se
demandent s'il y a une vie après la mort
une personne sur TR croit qu'il y a une
vie après la mort la mort certains
Français l'ont frôé de près et affirment
avoir vécu une expérience de mort
imminente d'un coup je sens que je sors
de mon corps journaliste écrivain et
réalisateur Stan Alix affirme lui à
travers le titre choc de son dernier
ouvrage que la mort n'existe pas la mort
est un moment de métamorphose qui se
caractérise par une continuité de notre
conscience tandis que Laura qui a vécu
une expérience de mort imminente sera
sur notre plateau Stéphan Alix qui a
effectué de nombreuses recherches sur
l'uddelà nous dévoile ce soir dans TPMP
le résultat de 15 ans d'enquête sur
l'aprè-ve c'est le livre du moment la
mort n'existe pas c'est le bestcellerire
du moment disponible depuis le 4 octobre
aux éditions Harper Collins euh alors
euh merci Stéphan Alix d'être là ça ça
passionne tout le monde je sais qu'il y
a plein de gens qui me disent on attend
cette séquence depuis le début de
l'émission euh vous vous présenter comme
quelqu'un de plutôt cartésien et
pourtant après le décès de votre frère
dans un accident de voiture en
Afghanistan en 2001 vous décidez de vous
intéresser au sujet de la vie après la
mort vous avez donc enquêté de façon
scientifique sur le sujet et vous avez
donc sorti ce livre que s'est-il passé
pour vous pour vous après la mort de
votre frère bah comme la plupart des
gens qui sont touchés par un deuil c'est
c'est stupéfiant c'est inattendu ça ça
ouvre plein plein de questions mon frère
est mort il avait 30 ans j'avais 32 ans
à l'époque et euh et voilà ça ça ouvre
tout un champ de questions qui sont des
questions qu'on a peut-être dans
l'adolescence des grandes questions
existentielles qu'est-ce qu'on fait là
qu quel est le sens de la vie est-ce
qu'il peut y avoir une vie après sauf
que moi j'étéis ni euh philosophe ni euh
expert en théologie j'avais envie de
réponses de journalistes des réponses
concrètes et scientifiques et vous en
avez eu vous en avez eu euh lors de vos
études vous avez rencontré euh des cas
de mort imminente est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner des exemples parce que c'est
vrai que ça euh ça passionne les gens et
ça nous passionne et ça vraiment ça ça
ça nous intrigue est-ce que vous pouvez
nous rappeler il paraitt qu'il y a
l'histoire de l'homme et de son dentier
c'est quoi cette histoire bah ça c'est
c'est un des cas de de témoignag qui a
été rapporté dans une étude scientifique
publiée dans une revue qui s'appelle The
Land 7 c'est un monsieur qui est arrivé
aux urgences en dans le coma il était
scianosé donc bleu euh on a tenté de le
ranimer l'équipe s'est acharnée à
essayer de le ranimer parce qu'il était
assez jeune donc il s'est dit on a
peut-être une chance de le de le ramener
et l'infirmière qui a essayé de
l'intuber a vu qu'il avait un dentier
donc elle a enlevé le l'appareil
dentaire elle l'a intubé il a fallu 1 he
et3 avant le de le ramener à la vie et
une fois qu'il était ramené à le vie il
a été emmené en salle de réveil et quand
il s'estevit il dit mais où est mon
dentier et personne ne trouvait le
dentier et et puis une semaine à peu
près après son son admission
l'infirmière qui l'avait inbé qui était
parti en congé est revenu à l'hôpital et
quand il la voit arrivver dans sa
chambre dit mais c'est elle c'est elle
qui sait où est mon dentier pendant que
vous étiez unement ranimé je vous ai vu
enlever mon dentier j'étais au plafond
je vous ai regardé je vous ai vu le
mettre sur un chariot de secours et je
vous ai vu m'intuber et me sauver donc
il est ah ouais et des cas comme ça bah
comme ce que pourra raconter Laura
éventuellement c'est c'est des cas
extrêmement fréquents la partie de
sortie hors du corps la partie où la
personne qui vit un arrêt cardiaque un
accident de voiture un accident sur un
bloc opératoire au lieu d'être
inconsciente comme a priori elle devrait
l'être puisque son cerveau fonctionne
plus ou très mal elle est au plafond en
train de regarder ce qui se passe elle
est donc qu é entre la vie et la mort
c'est quoi bah le cerveau il est en
sessation d'activité au bout d'un arrêt
cardiaque 10 secondes après un arrêt
cardiaque le cerveau il stoppe d'êt
irgué donc il ne fonctionne plus il est
en pause il est en standby donc là a
priori plus d'expérience de conscience
possible et pourtant 20 % des personnes
qu'on RAM è un arrêt cardiaque disent
non seulement avoir été consciente mais
extrêmement consciente avoir vu le
tunnel la lumière c'est les tous les T
les RC c'est quoi les les récits parce
que c'est vrai le tunnel la lumière
est-ce qu'on peut revenir àdessus c'est
tous les mêmes ils disent quoi bah c'est
une expérience de qui est difficile à
décrire déjà pour les personnes qui qui
les ont vécu parce qu' il y a comme une
espèce d'intensité de vie que tu n'as
pas au quotidien dans notre existence
donc déjà c'est compliqué qu'est-ce que
ça une vie plus intense que notre
réalité donc il décrivent cette
intensité il décrivent une lumière qui
n'est pas éblouissante qui qui rayonne
d'amour ils décrivent la rencontre
parfois avec des proches des ou avec des
figures spirituelles des êtres de
lumière c'est assez récurant il y a
vraiment des constances quel que soit le
pays quel que soit le le le c'est quoi
donc un moment il voit un tunnel avec la
lumière un tunnel avec la lumière et il
y a souvent un moment de non retour un
moment où ils ont l'impression de
pénétrer dans dans cette ce qui
ressemble pour eux à la mort et à un
moment il y a soit une phrase qu'
l'aurait dite soit quelqu'un qui
apparaît qui dit non c'est pas le moment
tu dois revenir et là il y a un
mouvement de recul de de retour vers le
corps je me souviens d'un patient qui
m'a dit j'ai l'impression de réintégrer
mon corps comme quand on renfile une
combinaison de plongé mouillé après
l'avoir extrait c'est froid c'est
douloureux c'est étriqué alors qu'ils
étaient dans quelque chose de de d'une
grande félicité mais moi pour le
journaliste que je suis il y a un
élément de ces expériences qui pour moi
est vérifiable et intéressant c'est la
partie où ils sont hors de leur corps et
ils décrivent cette promené dans le bloc
où ils étaient opérés par exemple ou sur
la scène de l'accident ou parfois assez
à distance comment expliquer que des
personnes qui sont dans un état comme ça
avec un cerveau qui fonctionne plus du
tout ou très mal puissent puissent
décrire des choses qui se passent dans
une pièce à côté dans un bloc opératoire
et des des cas comme ça il y en a pas un
il y en a pas 10 il y en a des centaines
de milliers incroyable alors est-ce que
vous pouvez nous raconter pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent à
21h avec vraiment la mort n'existe pas
le livre de Stéphan Alix que vous pouvez
nous raconter cette histoire du
chirurgien qui fait la poule bah ça
c'est encore un autre cas qui est assez
rigolo enfin rigolo ouais c'est un un un
patient qui a subi une opération à cœur
ouvert et qui va voir un psychiatre qui
est un de mes amis que je connais bien
euh à qui il explique avoir vécu pendant
son opération une expérience de MT
imminante classique il est sorti de son
corps et il dit mais d'ailleurs il y a
un truc qui m'a interloqué c'est que
j'ai vu le chirurgien qui était en train
d'opérer mon cœur et d'ailleurs j'étais
en train de voir où il était en train de
travailler sur le l'infarctus j'ai vu
mon chirurgien faire la poule et le le
le le psychiatre dit mais qu'est-ce que
vous voulez dire bah il était comme ça
et puis il battait des ailes comme s'il
était une poule donc le mon ami
psychiatre est interloqué il dit mais je
connais le chirurgien parce qu'il est
dans le même hôpital donc il va voir le
chirurgien et le chirurgien est
d'origine japonaise et déjà extrêmement
surpris qu'on lui dise ça et dit bah
effectivement je fais pas la poule mais
euh là où j'ai appris la chirurgie pour
éviter de contaminer les objets ou les
les ustensiles de chirurgie j'ai
l'habitude de poser mes mains sur mon
poitraille et de désigner à mes
assistants les objets à prendre le
bistouri et cetera donc le le le type il
avait la poitrine ouverte le cœur dans
la main du chirurgien qui était un train
justement d'opérer son infarctus comment
est-ce que il peut on peut expliquer en
s'imaginant que le cerveau fabrique la
conscience parce que ça sert la grande
thèse que je démonre dans le livre on
vit comme s'il était une évidence que
notre cerveau fabrique notre conscience
que notre cerveau fabrique qui nous somm
or quand le servot ne fonctionne pas 20
% des gens ont une expérience de grande
conscience une âme c'est ça c'est la
preuve de l'âme en fait cette histoire
selon vous que se passe-t-il pendant que
quelqu'un décède bah on change on il y a
une forme de continuité il y a un un
maître spirituel tibétain qui m'avait
donné cette image assez parlante il m'a
dit vous voyez quand qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand vous dormez vous êtes dans
votre lit vous fermez les yeux vous êtes
conscient puis moment vous perdez
connaissance et vous vous réveillez vous
êtes en train de rêver vous êtes dans
votre Rê vous savez pas que vous rêvez
vous savez pas que vous êtes endormi
vous êtes dans une nouvelle réalité
celle du rêve la mort d'après ce maître
tibétain c'est un peu la même chose
c'est que tu es tu es dans ton lit enfin
es dans ton lit tu es là où tu es en
train de décéder il y a quelque chose
qui lâche il y a une perte de
connaissance et puis tu reprends
conscience tu comprends pas trop ce qui
se passe tout de suite peut-être tu peux
trop comprendre très rapidement
peut-être ça pe prendre du temps souvent
les personnes qui décèdent dans un
accident comme mon frère par exemple
accident de voiture bah ça va être un
petit peu stupéfiant parce que tu
t'attends pas à mourir comme ça d'un
mais alors ça veut pas dire que tu vas
en enfer ça veut pas dire que tu vas
devenir une amérante ou un fantôme c'est
juste un moment d'un peu de surprise qui
va demander un certain temps
d'adaptation il y a une forme de
continuité les scientifiques parlent de
continuité de la conscience il y a pas
d'arrêt tu veux nous on s'imagine que le
cerveau s'arrête tu meurs c'est fini il
y a plus rien non il y a pas d'arrêt ça
continue ça continue plus dans notre
corps et on fait quoi après al bah ça
c'est ah ouis on sa pas ça reste un
mystère moi je me suis déjà borné
continue je me suis comment il y a un
copyright comm non mais c'estrai c'estou
vous êtes déjà m' dit vous êtes déjà
voulez me dire quelque chose moi je me
suis déjà essayé de de attaquer à à
vérifier que les preuves scientifiques
attestant que la conscience survit à la
mort du corps existe et sont
suffisamment présentable et compilable
c'est ce que j'ai rassemblé dans ce
bouquin après qu'est-ce qui se passe
après ça sera peut-être le tome 2 oui ou
l'émission de demain bah oui avec
plaisir on va on va parler de de plein
de choses c'est quoi le le Remote
Viewing utilisé par la CIA bah ça c'est
une des techniques qui permet de montrer
justement que notre cerveau n'intervient
pas dans certains de nos capacités de
perception c'est la ça s'appelle la
vision à distance et ça été utilisé par
les services de renseignement américains
de l'armée de la CIA pour espionner à
distance c'est les voyants c'est les
voyants le le le programme s'appelait le
programme Stargate il a été starte
Stargate starte ah ou d'accord oui il a
été évalué par le Congrès américain tout
ça est officiel toutes les sources sont
dans le bouquin c'est pas du tout des
des fantasmes qui sortent d'une série
télévisée c'est vraiment des choses qui
ont été étudié donc il y a eu des
centaines de missions par exemple je
connais bien des un des espions qui
s'appelait Joe mmegel enfin s'appelle
toujours JO mon gueule à qui on
demandait dans une pièce de sa base
militaire aux États-Unis d'aller voir ce
qui se passait dans un un un bunker
bizarre au fin fond de la mer Baltique
en Union soviétique il y va comme s'il
sortait de son corps il voit dans le
dans le bâtiment une énorme structure il
revient en disant j'ai l'impression que
c'est en train de construire un
sous-marin géant ses analystes lui
disent non mais n'importe quoi un
sous-marin géant ça peut pas c'est pas
possible refaites une mission il repart
là-bas il décrit le sous-marin il décrit
la structure et il dit bah d'ailleurs ce
sous-marin il va être mis en service
dans quelques mois d'ailleurs tout le
monde se fout de lui parce parce que là
c'est vraiment trop énorme et puis c'est
4 mois après les les satellites
américains qui survolent la zone en
permanence voient un sous-marin géant à
ponter un autre sous-marin soviétique
c'est les classes les sous-marins de la
classe typhon qu'on a vu dans le film
avec Shan Connery à la poursuite de
doctob rouge bah voilà ce voyant avait
vu la mise en place de ce sous-marin 4
mois avant qu'il soit photographié par
les Américains et des missions comme ça
il y en a des centaines et ça ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on a en nous
mais toi aussi tous on a une capacité
voir à l'extérieur de notre corps ça
peut être on peut être formé à ça moi je
l'ai été c'est stupéfiant ça marche
quand tu es voyant de naissance
quand je reviens dans 5 minutes pas
nécessairement voyage astral c'est le
voyage astral c'est ce que certains
appent le VO astral ah ou je quand on
sort de son corps pour all VoyaG je la
semaine prochaine non
non c'est quoi la conscience dont vous
parlerah c'est les religions parlent de
l'âme moi je parle de conscience
fondamentale c'est une démission une
dimension que nous portons qui nous
constitue qui n'est pas liée à
l'activité de notre cerveau nous on
pense que la conscience c'est notre
sentiment d'être nous-même notre
individu notre personnalité et que c'est
forcément lié à l'activité de notre
cerveau or tout ce que je présente dans
le bouquin démontre que quand notre
cerveau ne fonctionne plus on continue
d'être conscient est-ce c'est l'âme
c'est voilà une dimension fondamentale
qui nous constitue et qui est immortelle
justement n Laura Blanchon qui est avec
nous qui a vécu une expérience de mort
imminente entendre son histoire et elle
est incroyable vous avez une méningie
foudroyante oui euh vous êes êtes resté
10 jours dans le coma et vous êtes
finalement miraculeusement revenu à la
vie est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter
votre expérience de mort imminente que
les téléspectateurs quand vous allez
elle va vous raconter ça c'est vrai que
c'est c'est c'est c'est incroyable
lorsque je suis tombée dans le coma euh
j'ai vécu une sortie de corps c'estàd
que le souvenir que j'ai en me
réveillant du coma c'est c'est de me
voir au-dessus de mon corps ouais de
voir les machines mon frère mon père je
pouvais tout resituer dans la pièce et
je pouvais même dire ce qu'il m'avait
dit alors qu'à ce moment-là
l'électro-encéphalogramme il était plat
donc pas d'activité cérébrale
ensuite mon père me dit et je l'entends
je préfère que tu meurs plutôt que tu
souffres et à ce moment-là j'ai
l'impression de m'envoler de partir et
j'arrive dans une atmosphère
bienveillante je me suis jamais senti
aussi bien que que là-bas ah ouais et
ensuite c'est des séries de Rê pendant
le quand je me réveille du coma je je
raconte tous ses rêves et je fais des
liens et entre autres bah je vois mon
arrière-grand-mère qui qui prend soin de
moi je rencontre aussi une personne âgée
que je ne connais pas qui m'explique
qu'il est là pour prendre soin de moi et
que je vais repartir que je vais revenir
vous avez vu le le grand-père de votre
mari sa maison alors qu'elle ne vous
connaissez aucun des deux les souvenirs
de ce rêve là que je raconte je décris
le le grand-père la maison les arbres le
poulailler je peux tout vous situer
comme on se souvient d'un rêve et en
parlant avec ma famille ma belle famille
de mes rêves ma belle famille me dit dit
on direct que tu racontes la maison de
chez pépé c'est fou donc mon beau-père
m'a emmené dans cette maison à à 4h de
chez moi et on retrouvait tout au même
endroit il manquait une chose c'était un
seul pleureur qui n'était pas qui était
dans mon rêve et qui n'était pas dans le
jardin et mon mari m'a emmené et il y
avait une souche d'arbre il m'a dit
quand j'étais petit il y avait il y
avait un seul pleureur à cet endroitouf
c'est ouf alors incroyable votre
histoire c'est quoi cette histoire de
restaurant chinois pardon C histoire de
restaurant chinois parce que je disais
qu'il y a des rêves qui sont
inexplicables comme celui-là mais il y a
des rêves qui sont aussi explicables euh
je me souviens que ma mère m'emmène dans
un restaurant chinois et qu'elle me
tient et qu'elle m'étouffe avec une
amande ah ouais ça fait partie des rêves
et lorsque je raconte à ma mère ma mère
me dit mais en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'il fallait te réintubé et tu
étais trop tu bougeais trop je t'ai tenu
avec l'équipe soignante et il y avait
une personne asiatique qui sentait fort
la nourriture asiatique qui te tenait
avec moi et donc dans mon cerveau ça
s'est transformé en restaurant chinois
et ma mère qui essayait de m'étouffer
mais là pour le coup ce rêve là on peut
faire des liens avec ce qui s'est passé
dans la vraie vie mais pas pas sur les
autres h c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable mais ce qui est fou c'est que
les histoires sont incroyables et
toujours positives c'estàdire vous êtes
dans un allo vous discutez avec des gens
il y a jamais de sensation désagréable
tout es toujours dans un univers
merveilleux je sais que ça existe mais
pour moi ça a été une belle expérience
vraiment j'ai jamais été aussi bien qu'à
ce momentlà et je voulais pas revenir ah
vous vouliez plus revenir ah oua c'est
je me suis réendor j'ai eu la sensation
de me rendormir et je me suis réveillée
à l'hôpital ouais mais il y a des
personnalités he qui ont vécu des ce
qu'on appelle Near Death experience
expérience de mort imminente Philippe
Lab qui travaille sur C8 a raconté qu'il
avait vécu ça
et il raconte effectivement qu'il est
au-dessus du corps et il y a toujours C
ces choses de de le couloir lumineux ou
de bien de bienveillance d'apaisement il
y a Mund aussi ou m'a écrit en direct il
m'a dit aussi il avait vu il a vu il a
vu une lumière je dit non c'est juste
les pH de ma voiture
non mais c'est vrai il est con est-ce
que est-ce que vous vouliez plus revenir
c'est ça qui est
fou ouais il est total et en plus tu
penses même pas à tes parents ou à ton
copain que tu as laissé tu penses plus
qu'à toi c'est très égoïste mais c'est
plus rien ne compte plus rien ne compte
juste c'est un bien-être total
alors juste Stéphane qu'avez-vous qu
qu'est-ce qu'on peut découvrir après la
mort c'est quoi B que ça continue moi je
trouve que c'est déjà une bonne nouvelle
ça pour genre ça continue mais il y a
quoi parce que il y a il y a des Y a so
soiré il y a du
P je pense que je pense que quelqu'un
qui qui apportera une réponse détaillée
sur cette question là faudra s'en méfier
parce que c'est c'est une question
tellement vertigineuse que on sort un
peu de mon domaine de compétence moi je
suis journaliste je suis pas encore une
fois théologien donc je me suis contenté
déjà de de montrer que le mythe moderne
notre croyance moderne qui postule que
notre cerveau fautc notre conscience
c'est une hypothèse qui tient pas la
route après que devient notre conscience
quand elle est plus prisonnière de notre
cerveau quand tout d'un coup elle
regagne ce que dit leura et ce que
disent beaucoup de témoins d'expérience
de mort imminante c'est qu'ils ont
l'impression de se réveiller en vivant
cette expérience de mort imminante comme
si là on vivait dans une forme de
sommeil euh alors est-ce qu'on se
réveille est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire une réalité plus grande on a
plus de limitation d'espace et de temps
on peut se déplacer dans le temps et
dans l'espace sans que ça pose le
moindre problème l'URA s'est déplacé à
une certaine distance il y a des témoins
qui disent je suis parti à 4000 km en
une fraction de seconde comme ça ouais
donc ça va faire des économies hein ça
oui en fait ce qui est magnifique c'est
que grâce à votre livre on arrive à
matérialiser l'existence vraiment de
l'âme et on comprend du coup que dans
cette vie c'est important de prendre
soin de son corps effectivement mais de
son âme aussi parce que son âme c'est
celle qu'on va continuer à garder et
donc faire le bien pour le bien de son
âme important c'est important de faire
le bien parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
rend notre âme plus belle parce qu'on va
la garder pour toutes les prochaines
compte ça parce que moi j'ai j'ai des
points
Mo mais j'ai des MOS merci de ça parce
que pour moi c'est vraiment important
notre âme notre dimension spirituelle
elle va pas forcément se révéler au
moment de la mort cy elle est là
maintenantelle s'ime comment St pour
regagner des points comme ça l'âme elle
s'exprime comment pour toi pour tous les
gensme elle a chanté
Estelle not notre âme elle s'exprime à
travers notre intuition notre cerveau
non seulement il fabrique pas notre âme
mais écrase il l'empêche de s'exprimer
et donc tous les moments où on réussit à
se reconnecter à son intuition c'est
notre âme qui nous parle c'est notre âme
qui et notre âme elle connaît les
réponses elle connaît les les grandes
les grandes orientations de notre vie
elle est capable cette intuition parfois
de nous nous amener sur le chemin qui va
être vraiment le chemin de de notre
vraie cohérence intérieure quoi et c'est
c'est en sens et c'est notre cerveau qui
peut nous contre qui peut nous induire
en erreur normalement il faut écouter
son âme et parfois notre tête nous fait
prendre son âme que faut essayer de
découvrir comment son intuition
s'exprime à travers soi pour bien la
différencier de nos désirs de nos de nos
fantasmes secrets mais on a tous une
petite voix la petite voix de notre âme
à l'intérieur de nous et je pense que un
une des magies de la vie c'est d'essayer
d'apprendre à l'écouter et à en tenir
compte le plus souvent possible dans
notre existence ben en tout cas je vais
continuer à écouter l'âme et non mais
c'est vrai qu'elle chante pour ceux qui
sont loin de chez eux je l'embrasse fort
merci Stéphan Alix d'avoir été avec nous
merci également Laura et vous prépare un
bouquin merci à vous merci d'avoir été
avec nous c'éit incroyable oui merci
tout de suite c'est les chevaliers duel
en direct sur
C